♫ Pizza in the morning,
pizza in the evening
♫ Pizza at suppertime ♫
(upbeat instrumental music)
- That Little Caesar’s, you know,
they got a soft spot in my heart
because they got me through college.
- I definitely have always hated Dominos.
- Yeah, I mean, if it’s
there I’m gonna eat it.
- [Voiceover] Grease, mm!
- Oh, that’s greasy.
Which is perfect.
- That’s the most
important thing, is if you
can hold it out and it stands on its own.
- They’ve got some good sauce on here.
- The crust is pretty bread-y.
- I know this cheese, I feel like.
- I think this is Little Caesars.
- I think so too.
You know how I can tell?
- How?
- [Guy] The bottom of it.
- That’s like the pizza you
get in elementary school.
- I’m gonna, like, be
passed out after this.
I can tell you that right now.
- We got a little crumbly,
what I believe is garlic,
on the crust.
- This is like a good slice.
This is a heavy slice.
- The cheese is like, hella cheesy!
- This pizza does not have enough sauce.
- They went out of their way
to throw some more spices in.
- I think this is a better
slice of pizza than the first.
- Mm, for sure.
- This was like borderline a lunchable,
(laughing)
and this one is like
oh man, there is some love put into this.
- Number three looks like
bullshit is what this is.
(laughs)
- This has got different
sizes of pepperoni on it.
- Not enough sauce for me!
I’m a sauce girl all the way.
- I think this is pretty good.
Although it doesn’t
really taste like pizza.
- This is like pizza
you’d get in an airport.
(laughs)
- It’s a little too
boozey, like they’re trying
to make it a little too fancy for me.
- Alright, this one is hands down
the poorest looking pizza.
- This is Pizza Hut.
- Are you sure?
- I am not.
(laughs)
- It smells like a play place.
- It’s got, like, a ditch before the crust
where the sauce really collects,
and it’s way too intense.
- Soft crust.
Not bad.
- Papa Johns has
always lacked on the crust.
Like, their crust is back.
- Get in my mouth!
I ain’t waiting for you.
- You know what, I know this is Pizza Hut
by the crust.
- Yeah.
Exactly.
- Cause Pizza Hut has good crust!
- This is good, this is,
it’s a little fluffy.
- It does kind of taste like bread you get
before your meal at some restaurant,
just with, like, cheese
and pepperonis on top.
- It just tastes like butter.
Like butter bread with cheese on top.
- I’m all about that, so...
(laughing)
- I think this one is the best.
- 100% this one is my favorite.
And I know that it’s Pizza Hut.
- I think this one was my favorite.
- I thought this was the best, too.
But I still think it’s Papa Johns.
- Dominos. What we think is Dominos.
- That is my favorite.
It is so good.
Dominos, you stepped up your game.
- [Both] One, two, three.
(bell rings)
- Yes!
Dominos.
- Dominos.
They’re really killing it.
- Goddamn, Dominos.
- I noticed the cheese,
lighter on the sauce,
but I noticed it; that garlic seasoning.
Oh.
- I’m not doing that again.
We’re not getting pizza
again, Little Caesars.
- Tell me that you care, or I’m leaving.
- [Both] Pizza pizza!
- Goddamnit, Little Caesar.